- What up, Instagram?
Caleb and I got fucked real good.
What time is it?
7:50?
We were supposed to take off at 3:30.
So here we are, four hours
and 20 minutes later.
And we're, we're, we're
not anywhere close.
We're just fucking crushed here.
I was about to go sit
court-side next to Drake.
Stuck here in Toronto.
But I gotta get home.
(Fear of God by Lil Keed)
♪ Yeah, yeah, I call Gary Vee ♪
♪ Know he gonna give me
advice 'bout it, woo! ♪
♪ Shit, damn, in the
hotbox, we got jammed ♪
♪ Yeah, we scrammed in that
Lam', in that 'Ventador ♪
♪ Yeah, hit her on the balcony, uh ♪
♪ Yeah, then I'm passin' it, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, fur on my Gucci slides ♪
- What time do I have to be at the place?
- [Tyler] So, you start the
meet-and-greet at 12:15.
So, right now, it's 11:24.
- Oh, 12:15. So maybe I should just go to,
where do you want me to go?
- [Tyler] Dude, it'd be
most ideal for you to just
go to the event.
- Okay.
- [Tyler] Meet the guys.
They're gonna be right there,
you're all gonna walk in together,
you get a little time in the green room,
and then you'll be at the meet-and-greet.
- All right, that's what I'll do.
- [Tyler] Cool.
(Fear of God by Lil Keed)
♪ Fear of God on the shoes ♪
♪ And my pockets on the Bible ♪
♪ And for these millions ♪
♪ I'll kill all rivals ♪
- How much Q &A can I do?
- You can do pretty much
whatever the fuck you want.
- Is there mics in there?
- We can--
- Yeah, set that up.
Q & A is like, yeah.
- You can tell her?
- Get as many runners, or whatever,
how you do it, because it will work.
- Cool.
- Okay?
- [Man In Maroon Suit] How
do you keep up on searching?
- I do it.
- [Man In Maroon Suit] I know
that, but how do you do it?
- Because it's important.
Like, it's literally like asking someone,
you know what you just asked me?
How do you brush your teeth?
How do you shower?
Like, to me, being a
contemporary communicator
has always been, and forever will be,
the singular power.
Muhammad Ali's greatness
was not in the ring.
was outside the ring,
in understanding how to
manipulate the media of the time.
Muhammad Ali understanding
that he needed to be
best friends with Howard Cosell
is far more brilliant
than anything he ever did
in Zaire in the ring
against George Foreman.
It's why he was such a great boxer.
The same way that
Muhammad Ali rope-a-doped
George Foreman in Africa,
he rope-a-doped society
when he was doing something
extremely not popular.
And became a legend.
If you look back at anybody we know,
Gandhi, Ali, Martin Luther King,
if you really look carefully
at people we speak about,
they understood media.
They did something else,
an activist, an athlete, a
songwriter and performer,
but what they really did
was understand media.
And that's what I understand.
And so, to me,
I would give up anything
else for it, professionally.
And that's what's so interesting.
I think people hear,
that's why I kind of started
with the word social media.
People hear social media and
they think in business terms,
and in life, but like just keep it narrow.
They think of it as a
sprinkle on a cupcake.
I think it's the fucking batter.
(light laughter)
And that's the punchline.
(laughter)
So how do I keep up with it?
It's a prerequisite for my ambitions.
(hopeful music)
About to go on stage here at
the Real Estate Conference.
Bunch of people in there, lot of energy.
I'm pretty excited about it.
- Got it?
- Thank you.
It's also the first day of the NBA finals,
which is in Toronto today.
So the energy is super huge,
and I'm excited about it.
- [Announcer] Please
welcome Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
- Hello.
Hello, hello.
Thank you.
- I have some
terrible anonymous internet bullies,
and they ruined my life.
- Yup.
- And when they really bullied
me a couple of years ago
they made my account
lose thousand of people,
- Makes sense.
- And they just
took away my business at the time.
And I got started again
and have grown a great following again,
and have great sales coming in
and they've started up again.
- Okay.
Do you understand that that
is their issue, not yours?
- I do, but it's so,
- But?
- I struggle to be vulnerable.
- You're--
- It's very difficult to deal with
anonymous people spreading lies and rumors
because they're trying to ruin your life.
- So listen.
Let me tell you something
about the market.
The market is incredibly talented.
You are over-analyzing
their inability to not know the truth.
- [Advice-Seeking Woman]
You mean the market?
- The net market.
People leave comments
on my shit all the time,
and always did too.
People spend their whole
life because they're hurting.
People love to tear down
things out of their own pain.
You have a human, or two, or five,
or whoever this group is,
most likely a very small
group of one or two people
who are so hurt--
- [Advice-Seeking Woman]
It's their life mission!
- But you--
- It's hard to deal with.
- I'm gonna try to help you.
They have no say.
Any person that believes
their anonymous lies
is not a piece of business
that you want anyway.
(applause)
Got it?
There are plenty of people
who believe certain things
about me and that's lovely because
there's 7.7 billion people and
even if I keep crushing it,
in perpetuity squeezing
the fuck out of it,
I will never get to even a fraction of it.
Whatever you're losing
from those pieces of shit
have zero impact on your upside.
(applause)
You just don't see it
that way yet.
If every, listen to me!
If every single person
in this room believed it,
it's a drop in the fucking
bucket, in the market.
By the way,
the second you stop giving
it love and attention,
the second it stops getting
interesting for them.
(applause)
You're giving them the leverage.
When you realize you
have 99.9999999999999999%
of the world to focus on,
they will get real quiet
after you stop giving a fuck.
Hey guys.
- [Selfie-Seeking Fan]
Can I get a selfie quick?
- [Gary] Guys, I'm gonna miss my flight.
I'm so sorry.
- [Selfie-Seeking Fan]
Listen, you're awesome.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Security Guard] Come on man,
Gary's gotta catch his flight, guys.
- [Gary] You got a pen?
- [Selfie-Seeking Fan] Yeah.
- [Security Guard] Let's
go, let's go, let's go.
- I don't have a minute.
I'm gonna miss my flight.
I'm so sorry.
Let's go, Caleb.
- My bucket list.
- [Fan] Thank you so
much for your content.
- [Gary] You're welcome,
brother, thank you.
- [Driver] When's your flight?
- [Gary] Like in an hour.
It's gonna be tight.
All right.
Let's rock and roll.
- Sure.
Go this way to get into the--
(car honking)
There's a train, if that's cool.
Is that okay, Caleb?
- [Caleb] Yeah yeah.
Can you do it?
- Yeah, that was cool, and interesting,
and intense, and fun.
There was some good content.
- Thank you very much.
- You go ahead.
I'll meet you there.
(horror music)
- Flight got canceled.
And now we are just
- Fuck.
- figuring shit out. (laughs)
- It might have to be
an eight hour car ride.
- [Caleb] Like you're
thinking like rent-a-car, or?
- Car service.
- [Caleb] Car service?
Gotcha.
- [Woman Fan] It's Gary here.
- Yeah, it is Gary!
- (laughs)
- Is it really?
- Yeah!
(crowd murmuring)
- [Caleb] Forgive me for
asking, but do you want a mic?
- No.
- [Caleb] I figured, yeah.
- I feel like if we have to
drive eight hours to New York,
I'm gonna be like, fuck.
- [Caleb] (laughs)
If I'd told seventeen or
eighteen year old Caleb
that he'd be stuck in the
airport in Toronto with Gary...
(laughs)
- You're, uh, GaryVee, right?
- I am.
- Oh my God.
What's up man?
It okay if I get a quick pic?
That is so weird, I
didn't think I'd see...
- Have a good one.
- You too, brother.
- What are you doing in Toronto?
- I had a speech, then we got on a plane.
I was supposed to be home two hours ago.
- Oh my God, sorry to bug you.
- No, you're not bothering me at all.
- Have a good one.
- You take care.
(crowd murmuring)
Mic me.
(laid-back music)
The banana stand.
The banana peel stand.
We're ghetto around here.
You see that, Caleb?
Did you catch that?
- [Caleb] Scrappy as fuck.
- [Gary] Did you catch that?
- [Caleb] Of course.
- [Gary] The banana stand.
The banana peel stand.
We're ghetto around here.
You don't have to be fucking fancy.
When a banana peel's
your fucking equipment.
GaryVee, do I need good equipment?
No, motherfucker.
Use a banana peel.
What up, Instagram?
Caleb and I got fucked real good.
What time is it, 7:50?
We're supposed to take off at 3:30.
So here we are, four hours
and 20 minutes later.
And we're, (laughs) we're,
we're not anywhere close.
We're just fucking crushed here.
I was about to go sit
court-side next to Drake.
Stuck here in Toronto.
But I gotta get home.
I gotta get home, I gotta get home.
That's the reality.
Too bad 'cause I literally
would've gone court-side tonight.
And flexed on everybody.
Yo.
Oh, Harwood wants to come in here?
See if we can get Harwood.
Harwood's the man.
See if Ryan Harwood, CEO
of Gallery Media Group,
which runs ONE37pm and PureWow.
There he is!
And by the way, real quick.
Can we all agree that this man is ridic,
he's attractive, right?
- What an attractive man.
- He's super attractive.
- Thank you.
I appreciate that.
- Ryan, you're extremely attractive.
Caleb, do you see Caleb?
He's like so attracted to you, bro.
- [Caleb] (laughs)
- You are accurate in what you said there
in terms of self-esteem is why we didn't
need to do drugs when we were younger.
- Right.
We didn't care what all the other,
see, you were super popular.
I was popular in a different way.
Like you played in such
rarefied, true popularity air,
but you were still able
because of your own self-esteem
to not do things you
didn't believe in even
if very pretty girls or very cool guys
wanted you to do that.
- What's in here.
Ooh, compound.
You like that?
- Yeah, I like that.
- It's what's in there.
You gotta have conviction for that.
- Ryan, am I the most
confident man you've ever seen?
(laughter)
- I think Caleb is.
- I agree.
Ryan, actually, this is
fun to have you here.
Now we're business partners.
We were friends before that.
Like, I don't want this to be a,
I'm not trying to get some compliments.
I'm trying to think about this audience.
What thing can you tell everybody here
that you even, as a
friend, from the outside
who was closer to me
than most of my audience
like, maybe had a perception on,
and then when you got on the inside,
you saw a version of it,
And what did you learn from
that they can learn from that?
Like what is a very good
piece of, not advice,
an observation, now that
you're super under the hood,
what do you see that
maybe I don't even see
as a slight insight that
might help somebody here
take that next step because
they take for granted
what I say, but you've
actually seen it in real life?
Like what do you think
of when I say that shit?
- Yeah, what I think of is,
what I noticed that you do
which is super interesting
is that you really, when you talk about,
you like to talk about tripling
down on your strengths,
leaning into your strengths, et cetera.
What I've noticed is that you
do that to such an extreme
in the sense that you want to always play
where you have passion,
where you enjoy things,
and where your strengths lie.
And you really do push off things,
you have no interest in the things
that you don't have fun doing,
which is why you're
kind of always on a high
and why you always have that energy,
and why you're able to always be excited
about what's going on because
you just don't pay attention
to the things that you just don't want to,
and you hire people around you that
might be skilled in that,
or whatever it may be.
But it's funny,
I think a lot of people
probably hear you talk
on the internet and they're like,
yeah, it's all good in theory,
but is that really practical for someone
to live that 24 seven.
You know, I always considered myself
to be an incredibly positive person,
but I've never seen someone
live what they preach
24 hours, seven days
a week the way you do.
I preach a lot of positivity stuff,
but it's still very
difficult for me to maybe
live up to those standards at all times.
You literally are the
epitome and walking example
of everything you preach at
all times, which is bonkers.
That's pretty bonkers.
- (laughs)
- Anyone that says, like it's
so funny for me on the outside
to kind of like look at the comments
and like when people try to call you out,
you're like, this guy is bullshit,
or you know, this guy he says
he does it, but he doesn't.
And I just kind of like giggle and laugh.
I'm like, yeah, but he does.
- (laughing)
But I don't know if you saw
that I pinned Roddy's comment.
He wants to know if you've taken a poop.
- (laughing)
- I wanna tell everybody
who's watching right now,
Rodilitz, who's pinned
in the comments, and Ryan
have been best friends from birth.
I mean this, I mean this.
Back to like seeing things
that get you excited,
as I got to know these guys
maybe seven or eight years ago,
their true friendship actually
excites me and inspires me.
And I love your guys' friendship.
I really do.
All right, I gotta go.
I love you.
ONE37pm, everybody follow it.
I'll answer your question,
- Answer my text message.
- I will.
I have an eight hour, bro!
I got canceled here, my flight
got canceled in Toronto,
so I was either going to sit
court-side game one just now,
but I have a huge family
thing tomorrow morning,
so I've got to take and
eight hour drive from Toronto
to New York in a couple of minutes.
- How are you not staying
in Toronto for the finals?
- Because I got a big thing tomorrow.
- Got a big thing tomorrow.
Shout out to Jay Rosenzweig.
- Mmm, yeah,
who I probably would've
been sitting with tonight
if I could've stayed.
All right, see you.
All right, I'm gonna get settled.
I got a lot of catching up to do.
That was fun, man.
The 301, no, I don't fucking
remember this is amazing.
I love you, Irad.
You too, Dust.
I love all of you.
See you later.
(pulsing electronic music)
- [Caleb] For the long ass ride.
At the border almost.
(pulsing electronic music)
- [Caleb] Oh fuck.
That's crazy.
Wow, yeah!
Oh, shit!
That was cool.
- That was cool, huh?
- [Caleb] (laughs)
Here is my passport.
- [Driver] Do you have his?
- [Caleb] Yes.
- [Border Officer] Hi.
- [Driver] Hello, how are you?
- [Border Officer] I need you to lower
your rear window, please.
- [Driver] Oh, sorry.
- [Border Officer] And then
do you have some lights
you can turn on so I can see everyone?
All right, so you're just the driver?
- [Driver] Yes.
- [Border Officer] Okay.
(pulsing electronic music)
- [Gary] (snoring)
(laid-back music)
- [Gary] Short little ride.
(laughter)
Thank you so much.
- [Caleb] Obviously it doesn't have to be
anything elaborate,
but could we close out
the episode real quick?
- We made it.
(laid-back music)